la carcasse carbonisée d'un bus gisais
avenue Gramont depuis la nuit du 29 au
30 juin dernier à Tours soulevant les
interrogations et la perplexité des
riverains elle a été retirée ce vendredi
par une dépanneuse hors norme CE
cartoristique allemand n'avait pas été
enlevé plutôt pour des questions
d'assurance la semaine dernière la ville
avait mis en demeure la société
propriétaire de faire le nécessaire
Benjamin Watel
première manœuvre pour enlever le bus
l'attacher avec des chaînes et le
soulever pour le mettre sur le plateau
d'un camion
l'opération compliquée a nécessité
plusieurs heures de travail mais l'idée
c'est de mettre des chaînes sous le bus
de les raccrocher donc au bras au Mas de
la de la rotateur si bien que la
situation est quand même assez complexe
parce que le paramètre dont on ne
disposait pas c'est la qualité en fait
restante des de la ferraille du bus
brûlé on savait pas si elle allait se
disloquer lorsqu'on allait le soulever
les dépanneurs ont nettoyé l'intérieur
du bus en enlevant les débris et les
poussières métalliques pour éviter
qu'elle ne se retrouve ensuite sur la
route
des employés du réseau fil bleu se sont
assurés que le travail se faisait en
toute sécurité alors que les bus et les
tramways passaient à quelques mètres de
la carcasse justement le risque
sécuritaire c'était vis-à-vis d'une part
par rapport à l'exploitation du réseau
que l'on a pas arrêté et d'autre part le
risque électrique vis-à-vis de la ligne
aérienne de contact donc la caténaire
avait été incendié durant la nuit de
violences urbaines du 29 au 30 juin
dernier le voir partir était un
soulagement pour les riverains je suis
le bus a pris la route vers midi
direction la fourrière
il ne reste plus que quelques déchets au
sol pour rappeler son existence